- [Narrator] "Saved by the Bell" is a show
that defined the '90s.
Filled with topical lessons of the era.
- There's no hope with dope!
- [Narrator] And some
questionable fashion statements.
But nothing's more memorable
than the theme song,
and there's one guy to thank.
Meet Scott Gale, the man
responsible for all the music
for "Saved by the Bell."
- I'm Scott Gale.
(clock ringing)
My resume would include 2,000
episodes of network television
including "Saved by the Bell,"
"Golden Girls," "Empty Nest;"
and there were some others in there.
I first started getting
interested in music,
when I saw Elvis Presley on television
on "The Ed Sullivan Show."
I said I want to do that, and
I was about five years old.
Luckily my parents arranged
some guitar lessons for me.
I first moved to LA in
1972; my first big break
was music coordinator; I worked
on every episode of "The Golden Girls."
I got the first call at very
end of '89 from the producers
about working on a new television show,
and it was going to be
called "Saved by the Bell."
They told me that it might
make seven episodes, maybe not.
So, I put the phone
down, two minutes later
the song came out of me.
♪ By the time I grab my books ♪
♪ And I give myself a look ♪
♪ I'm at the corner just in
time to see the bus fly by ♪
♪ It's alright 'cause
I'm saved by the bell ♪
And it was like the luckiest
two minutes of my life.
And when they heard mine, they
said, "That's it, that's it."
I heard later that they did not want
the name of the show in the title,
but I did not get that note.
"Saved by the Bell" was competing
with cartoons at the time
because Saturday morning on
NBC there was no live-action
for kids, so everything
needed to be brash and happy
and lots of visual and lots of color.
Peter Engel, the executive
producer, he always told us,
"I want rock; I want it to be
happy; I want it to be driven;
"and I want it to rock."
No matter what the scene
was he wanted rock.
(pop music)
Most of the music was story oriented.
If there was a car crash
or a break up scene,
we write to the picture;
and we even wrote rap.
We did the best we could;
I'm not really a rapper,
but we laid down a beat
and the kids really,
they made the songs come to life.
(rap music)
I really loved working
on "Saved by the Bell"
because we had an opportunity to write
and perform so much music.
A lot of people growing up in
the '90s, that was their show.
People could relate to it;
I'm still a fan of the show.
It comes on all the time; I
never get tired of watching it,
and I never get tired of
seeing my name on the screen.
♪ It's alright 'cause
I'm saved by the bell ♪